it really feels like they look at marvel and
they see what they're doing and mostly just
shoot for that rather than shooting for why
and how that stuff actually works we don't
need to try to suddenly go back to we gotta make
everything heavily interconnected with each other
when that's what a lot of this ends up reading to
me like but then also seems a little contradictory
you're saying you have stuff like todd phillips's
joker and you want to do more of that but what
makes that movie good is it doesn't feel like it
needs to be connected because it's his own thing
what is up there reject nation greg and john
here today we are going to talk about some warner
brothers dc eu changes the company that just
can't seem to find a direction to stick through
get there someday despite the fact that they've
been doing pretty alright lately you know like
the batman was a pretty good hit the suicide squad
while not a big box office it supposedly did all
right on streaming it was really well received
by audiences and critics and the peacemaker the
peacemakers show i was getting there just wait
for me guys leave a like if you can that would
mean a lot i don't know if you guys know about
this recently discovery and warner brothers they
made a deal it's now called wb discovery i believe
the deal was made for one trillion dollars they're
just throwing money at this thing 43 billion
dollars i didn't really follow the lead up to
this merger because the only thing i ever heard
about it was does this mean the snyder burst will
be restored is it finally about to happen the
starter best restored kids they all say that
david zazlov loves that snyder variety put his
article yesterday morning from the time that we're
uploading this but i wanna do a total overhaul
on dc entertainment honestly going through it had
me uh a bit worried about the future okay so the
whole article you can find in the description box
but we want to focus on a few key points here so
we want to go within really fast and we're going
to talk about it afterwards so the first thing is
they want to have like a kevin feige like leader
i don't know if you guys know this but warner
brothers has tried to have a kevin feige likely
for quite some time doesn't sound bad in theory
obviously and like i said none of this actually
sounds necessarily like a terrible idea it's
just going off of track record past experiences
considering the fact that it seems like anyone
who tries to be the mcu they generally fail at
doing it here's what the article says before the
merger closed zoslov head of discovery now ahead
of both vetted candidates with experience in
creating and nurturing blockbuster intellectual
property with the goal of potentially finding
someone to serve as a creative and strategic
gaza similar to what marvel has in kevin feige one
insider suggests that zasalov was less interested
in finding a creative guru and more eager to hire
someone who had the type of business background
needed to keep all the different factions of dc
working more harmoniously that actually makes a
little bit of sense if they want to find a kevin
feige like leader but the thing that makes kevin
feige so special not just the fact that he's
a businessman but also because he really loves
marvel comics he really knows marvel and that's
why he has such a good connection with the fans
as well even when they make changes in the movies
generally speaking you can tell this guy actually
knows what marvel's really all about and now that
i have all these different other things going in
dc i get that you would need someone who could
also be like i need to know how to harmoniously
bring this all together you need somebody who's
invested in the breadth of characters and the
mythology but who also has a good business sense i
feel like they really need to split the difference
kevin feige likes story person who knows the
world but who also can keep things running
chop chop so they want to get dc eu back
to the point where everything feels more
connected basically you know part of me is like
part of making dc special to me is the fact of
how it doesn't feel any more like it's so reliant
on that which has allowed for other films that
were really filmmaker driven to really blossom but
we'll dive more into that in a second the article
goes on to say discovery insiders believe that
although dc has achieved cinematic success with
recent films such as aquaman and the batman and
lexa coherent creative and brand strategy yeah
i kind of agree with that they seem to shift their
plans all the time here depending on how each one
does at the box office they're very reactionary
yeah all the more reason to get somebody who
has a good business sense about these things
and discovery believes that several top shelf
characters such as superman have been left to
languish and need to be revitalized i thought
they were revitalizing superman in terms of
whatever that jj abrams michael b jordan one see
it's not dead i mean i've heard reports lately
that they're still trying to figure out the script
and maybe having some problems with that i feel
like that could easily change in a heartbeat if
they really find a track that they like and they
want more stuff like joker they also believe that
projects like top phillips joker are a shining
example of how to build second characters from
dc library and should be exploited margot robbie's
harley quinn is another example i'd be down for
another birds of prey absolutely despite the fact
that it causes a weird conversation on twitter i'd
be down for another birds of prey i quite enjoyed
that movie a lot and i think harley quinn was also
awesome in the suicide squad absolutely so yeah
i'd be totally down for that weirdly going online
that was the one that seemed to upset people a lot
was more more of a joke about like oh come on guys
have you not heard my scarecrow stand-alone movie
idea it almost seems like they could flourish just
doing standalone movies and not trying to be
marvel whatsoever i'm not against the idea of
producers executive producer studios having a say
in what's happening with the movies of course i'm
not against like that's fair they're putting the
money in it's just you know a movie [ __ ] when
you feel like this whole movie is just studio
notes a lot of this reads to me like i think
we'd be going back to everything feeling like
shoehorn studio notes i'm not saying that'll
be the case it just kind of communicates that way
to me right now whenever a studio even dc in the
past when they try to emulate more of the marvel
cinematic universe they keep writing themselves
into this weird corner with their films seem like
they've become all about setting up to get to some
crossover movie some build up that
ultimately doesn't end up paying off because
their plan getting there was not panning out and
they've already tried having leaders several times
now seems like what they've been doing lately has
been the best strategy so far which is let them be
more filmmaker driven films that's why i think the
batman has such a great response like i'm excited
for the gotham shows that matt reeves is working
on he's making like his own little bat burst and
what i think is really cool about what dcu has
on their hands is they're able to build universes
within universes really well with james gunn doing
the suicide squad he's got his like suicide squad
universe happening with the peacemaker series and
both i thought were really great stuff i'm already
under the impression though that especially
with your flash movie do you really need to
do this you're already setting up the multiverse
so one can just assume that they're connected via
the multiverse and that if it's not worried about
having crossovers or being totally connected like
we have to force robert pattinson to now cross
over into one of these films just establish that
yeah it exists it's connected because it's it's
within the dc multiverse itself what does this
mean for current films that they have in plan
too because i know that's also been put on halt
but i want the shazam trilogy to finish out i want
the aquaman trilogy to finish out let's see what
happens that ever heard i want to see everybody
wants to see what happens with aquaman three now
see what goes on there the absolute one and i
want them to do it yeah i mean it almost seems
like they have a perfect opportunity to just sort
of let everything be where it is and yeah move
forward with a better plan but i don't necessarily
think there needs to be a lot of retroactive
restructuring i mean yes you have a bit of a
disparate universe but from here on especially
with the multiverse i feel like it's not really
that famous last words difficult to kind of see
the lay of your land and then streamline it moving
forward and take the best of what's worked so far
and perpetuate that i mean that's essentially what
marvel's been doing just with a massive continuity
and maybe they'll find they don't need that
massive continuity so much as they need just a
universe that feels like it houses all these
characters or something i'm sure with marvel
there's constantly conversations i'm sure behind
the scenes of we need to re-strategize this we
need to fix this we've seen them shift like slots
in their films before and films have been canceled
here or there so of course they also will have the
discussion of re-strategizing it's a constant part
of game planning or mapping something out
this massive it's just when you tell me stuff
like they want a kevin feige like leader
like you you've already you're not
david we've always wanted that and i feel like
a lot of time they don't really understand
what's made kevin feige so great at what he's
done with marvel what they're doing right now
seems to be doing just fine because of the fact
that they have the multiverse at their disposal
that they've already established with crisis
on infinite ursa that are only gonna solidify
more with the flash movie we don't need to try
to suddenly go back to we gotta make everything
heavily interconnected with each other when that's
what a lot of this ends up reading to me like but
then also seems a little contradictory when you're
saying you have stuff like todd phillips's joker
and you want to do more of that but what makes
that movie good is it doesn't feel like it needs
to be connected because it's his own thing so much
of the time hearing about wb and and now discovery
and all the things they want to do with dc it
really feels like they look at marvel and they
see what they're doing and mostly just shoot
for that rather than shooting for why and how
that stuff actually works and i feel like there
is a sort of expectation that these things will
translate immediately and i feel like you know of
course they want a new kevin feige and for a more
you know vertically structured system but at the
same time that stuff takes time and a steady hand
to build and i think it's interesting that they
still prioritize at least as of this account
the business angle of that because you need the
heart and the soul of that and i get that even
marvel is subject to the business side and you
know how the market speaks but they also seem like
whenever they reshoot or whenever they
restructure they always make sure to temper
the characterizations and the emotional cores and
the spirit of those stories and those characters
in time with that rather than fully going for the
market so i feel like the biggest question to me
now is what kind of a business man is david zazla
yeah at this moment it sounds like the same plan
they've been shooting for for so long but we'll
see maybe they will restore the snyder verse i'd
like superman to come back as well just as much as
anyone else alrighty well leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell what do you think
about all this and we'll talk to you guys soon